[Musik]
neben dem machen heute 3 basic
milchshake rezepte milchshakes gehen
meiner meinung nach das ganze jahr über
ob im sommer oder winter vollkommen egal
wir starten jetzt mit den drei basics
schoko vanille und erdbeer und danach
können wir darauf aufbauen könnt ihr mir
zum beispiel jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben was ich noch für milch shakes
kreieren so zum beispiel zu freaks mit
donuts und oris oder auch also gesunde
wie zwischen bananen wichtig schreibt
mir einfach alles in die kommentare so
wir starten mit dem schoko sheikh dafür
habt ihr euch schokoladeneis
schokoladenstückchen außerdem natürlich
milch für den milchshake vanille extrakt
und ein bisschen crashed ice das ganze
geht entweder mit dem mixer oder aber
auch mit dem pürierstab das dürfte auch
gar kein problem sein
und schon ist der schoko schlagfertig so
jetzt machen wir weiter mit dem rtw
schick dafür nehmt euch je nach saison
entweder frische erdbeeren oder im
tiefgekühltem pc tiefgekühlte da die
habe ich ganz leicht antauen lassen so
ungefähr 10 minuten und da gebe ich
jetzt auch wieder alles was ich hier
habe in den mixer da habe ich dann die
erdbeeren natürlich vanille extrakt das
gehört immer dazu
milch und auch wieder crashed ice
[Musik]
lass mich raten jetzt kommt woher
wusstest du dass du bist kraftstoffes
krass so jetzt machen wir wir haben den
scheck und für den vanille sheikh
nämlich auch wieder vanilleeis
ich nehme wieder milch crashed ice und
ich nehme man immer exakt diesmal
verdoppele ich aber die dosis weil ich
möchte die volle vanille dröhnung und
das ganze auch wieder mixen übrigens ich
mich die ganze zeit das ist ja fast
echtzeit hierfür 10 15 sekunden also ihr
müsst dann nicht ohne ende mixen ein
bisschen reicht schon
[Musik]
wenn du mich jetzt fragt was ist jetzt
der leckerste scheck von den dreien das
ist die gemeinste folter frage die ihr
mir je stellen können wenn wir kommen es
immer darauf an auf die jahreszeit im
winter bin ich fan von schoko und
vanille und im sommer kaufe ich meinen
ersten scheck wird bei dir aus will
genau richtig lecker macht unbedingt
nach ihr habt gesehen wie easy peasy das
geht mega mega einfach und schreibt mir
in die kommentare wir am anfang schon
erwähnt schreibt mir was für kombination
ich machen soll das war jetzt nur das
ultra basic kokos sehr gut ich habe mir
sogar überlegt ob ich so ein bounty free
geschenk machen oder freaks sheikh aber
dann dürft ihr nicht mehr kann das so
viel kalorien hat dann könnte man sich
das halt mal okay ich wünsche euch jetzt
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten video chips eure
ki
[Musik]